okay so welcome everyone to today's
lecture my apologies for not being there
in person because of a health situation
in my family but let's do it on Zoom
okay so let's dive straight
in so so what have we learned so far uh
just a quick recollection we have had an
introduction to deep learning and then
for the last several lectures Ben has
been teaching you about physics and form
NE Network
or pins for solving pdes and what he has
done is that he has taught you
algorithms he has also taught you what
are the various successes of these
algorithms as well as a few limitations
right so this has been the content so
far and in today's lecture and also in
the lecture next week sort of the main
focus would be somehow to find out some
insights particularly some theoretical
insights into why pins work and what
particularly why they don't work so in
as you saw there were several
limitations of these methods why do
these limitations come off and what can
we do to solve it so that would be the
main main content of today's lecture and
a bit of the lecture next week so let's
get started uh just to sort of
recapitulate what pins are and to
introduce a bit of the notation because
since we're going to do a little bit of
theory I have to be more precise with my
notation and also more sparse in some
sense than one what Ben was was so first
of all so let's focus today on the
forward problem for the PD so as you all
know uh pins can also be used in the
context of inverse problems but I think
for the perspective of this lecture
let's focus on forward problems and then
the target is um to approximate the
solutions of this abstract PD so this is
an abstract PD as abstract as it gets
because we are writing everything in
terms of a differential operation data
uh D and in terms of uh input F and in
terms of the BD solution U right so
where are these objects defined so in
particular because our inputs so let's
let me as I said our input as well as
our solution so U is the PD solution
these objects are both functions right
so they have to live in some function
spaces so we say that the input lives in
a function space y this could just be
some LP space so LP simply means uh P
integrable functions so L1 would be
integrable functions L2 would be square
integrable functions and so on and
similarly U the solution this lives in
the Space X which is another function
space okay and these function spaces
they are defined on a domain so this
domain could be an open set in space or
it could be open set in space time
depending on whether the PD that we are
having is a steady state PD or whether
it's a Time dependent PD so this is sort
of the basic setup and so we have an
input to the PD and we have an output to
the PD so this is f is the input U is
the output and what links them together
is the differential operator right this
is pde has to have an underlying
differential operator and this
differential operator is the one which
takes the input which sits in the Space
X and goes all the way to the output
which sits in the space y right so this
is sort of the basic setup and this is
let's say that this spaces X and Y are
defined such that this differential
operator is well defined so now you can
ask me where are the boundary conditions
where the initial conditions so because
for time dependent PDS we need an
initial condition and for all PDS we
need boundary conditions so what I've
have done is just to keep notation
simple and straightforward uh these
conditions are actually implicit so in
the sense that they are already included
in the input F okay so when you have the
input F you you have the initial
conditions and the boundary conditions
that are included and in the concrete
example we always look at the heat
equation so this is a heat equation in
multi several space dimensions so in
this case the differential operator D
here is given in terms of the time
derivative the partial derivative with
respect to time and the laian with
respect to space and remember that the
laian um laian of d u is nothing but the
summation J from 1 to D of U XJ XJ so
you take all the second derivatives the
second derivative Matrix uh it's called
the Hessian and you just take the trace
and then you'll get the laian so this is
a concrete example so you take a
function U you apply the differential
operator the heat equation the heat
operator which is given here and then
you get uh the input so the task of
solving the PD is given this input F and
the differential operator D we have to
find the solution VI so this is very
very straightforward setup that you can
imagine and then how do we work with uh
pins how are pins going to solve it so
if you remember uh the first ingredient
of pins of course uh without saying much
are deep neural networks again I need
some notation because this is sort of my
notation so as you can imagine we have a
mapping which takes uh some input uh in
this case y if you remember
so D is the domain now so this sort of
caligraphic D is the domain and this
could depending on the context be just
um a subset of space or of space time
and this y now I didn't write it but
this y belongs to this caligraphic D
okay so these are the coordinates space
and time coordinates and then the Deep
neural network UST star is defined in
terms of all these layers uh that you
know very well each layer has two
elements to to it the first one is this
aine piece given in terms of a weight
Matrix W and bias Vector B BK and w k
for the K layer and then you also have
an activation function a scalar
activation function and because we are
going to differentiate sometimes many
times our activation function is
typically a sigmoid or a hyperbolic
tangent or something smooth not relu
which has discont potential
discontinuities in its derivatives and
the parameters so this is just the
neural network that defines um
ultimately goes in the pin algorithm and
the parameters the free parameters that
we are going to tune are the weight
Matrix is uh w k and the bias vectors BK
so this is sort of the basic setup
standard plain vanilla deep neuron
networks you have seen several examples
of them also in the tutorials now what
we do with pins is that we take this
deep neural networks we know what the
inputs are we Al know what the
differential operator is and we're going
to approximate the solution here U with
deep neuron networks right so this is
the basic objective the basic algorithm
so as I said means each of these um neur
networks are defined in terms of this uh
parameter Vector Theta and this
parameter Vector Theta is uh now given
by so it's here and this defines the
Deep Nur Network Q Theta and this is
what is going to approximate my solution
of the PD I don't know why there is a
star here let's say that it also belongs
to X or we could say that this was a
subset of X okay good so now aim
objective here is that we know that
there is a solution to the PD which we
we don't know what it is we are going to
find the Theta such that uh this guy
approximates this U and it approximates
it in a suitable sense and what is the
sense in which it approximates is what
we are going to talk about today but the
way way in which it does this
approximation is it doesn't have any
labels right it does not have access to
necessarily have access to values of you
all that it has to do is to work with
the inputs which are given by this F
here and by the differential operator
because we know what the differential
operator is so recalling what you do is
that you compute the PD residual so PD
residual remember that the PD is simply
D of U equals F right so now you just
apply instead of U you apply this
differential operator to U Theta and
take the difference here of course this
is not going to be zero because if you
lucky and it's zero then the problem is
solved without any error but in general
it will lead to what is called a
residual this is the residual with
respect to Theta and we can compute this
residual as I said by automatic
differentiation in general but also I
think pen told you that sometimes you
can also use finite differences but
let's say from our perspective we'll
just use automatic differentiation so
now at every point in principle we can
compute the residual of the PD for a
given neural network but of course um it
doesn't help to be able to compute it at
every point because at the end of the
day we have to take some sort of an
integral some sort of a um Global
quantity right because pointwise
quantities they're not really useful so
what we are going to do is that we are
going to take uh the lp Norm here of the
residual so we integrate it AC Ross the
domain we take an average in some sense
and usually the p is equal to 1 or two
so these are the two common spaces
although sometimes you might need
something else okay but for the time
being let's say that these are one or
two so now the objective is you find a
Theta such that this residual is going
to be minimized but of course this is an
integral and you can't just compute
integral by hands sorry integrals by
hand so what you have to do is to
replace this integral here by a
quadrature okay now this is sort of
standard in numerical analysis you
replace the integral by a quadrature and
to do so you just choose some so you
have a domain here D this is your domain
you throw some quad points in it this
could be random points okay usually the
simplest is to take random points but
that's not necessarily the best so it
there has to be a quadrature rule there
are some quadrature weights here and you
replace this integral out here with this
quantity here so this is a quadrature
this is an approximation of the integral
and then you take a Theta star you just
minimize this right so this is the loss
function now this is often called the
physics inform
loss because there is no supervision
here except for the initial and boundary
conditions which we have said are
implicit so we have some Physics inform
law and now you just uh this is of
course as as always in machine learning
this is a
High dimensional non-convex problem very
high dimensional non-convex problem and
we are going to use some stochastic
radient Dent right so this is the pins
algorithm that you take a class of
neural networks you compute the residual
in terms a pointwise by using automatic
differentiation and then use a
quadrature to approximate some Global
quantities minimize and you're done so
this is the algorithm and I think Ben
Ben has explained this algorithm shown
many examples of this and you could say
that in some sense it works I mean this
a question does it work so for instance
some some sense it does work so here is
the multid heat equation remember this
is U minus llan of t u equal Z so this
is the multid heat equation now D here
changes all the way from 1 to 100 so
this is um a very high dimensional pde
you'll see later why we care about that
and then we fix the pin here the neural
network uh width it's just four layers
so you have four four layers 20 neurons
in each layer not at all a big neural
network and then we need quite a few
quadri points because we have so many
dimensions and then we try to do this
approximation procedure right so this
can be done and the all the points here
so these interior points and Boundary
points these are sort of random points
because in very high
Dimensions nothing else works right you
just have to take random points and when
you do that then you see that for the
same network somehow and for the same
amount of training time you'll see that
there is a increase in error it's of
course very very small for very small
dimensions and as you go up in
Dimensions the error does increase but
it's not increasing exponentially or
anything if you see now from going from
20 to 50 it is roughly doubling which is
what you would expect and then from 50
to 100 it's also less than doubling so
you would say that this is a linear
increase which is the minimum so in some
sense it does not have what is called a
curse of dimensionality curse of
dimensionality would be for instance if
you would have an exponential increase
right here this is not not at all the
case so at least for this simple example
where the complexity comes from the fact
that you have lots of Dimensions because
in general you know you can't solve the
heat equation in 100 Dimensions using
the finite difference methods that I I
taught you in one of the lectures so it
somehow works right but then you have
also seen other examples where it
doesn't work so how do we know when it
works when it doesn't work why does it
work why doesn't it work and so on so
this will be the focus of the next
couple of lectures so let us get started
uh of course if you have any questions
you can always ask me in the chat button
okay this is always possible from time
to time or you can raise your hands uh
if you're so inclined so either of the
options is is there we can still make it
interactive even if we all on Zoom
nevertheless let's let's go ahead and
let's try to address this question right
why does why do they work sometimes and
why don't they work sometimes okay so
then uh again I go back to the abstract
PD because then the notation becomes
very very light and you sort of see the
abstract structures the mathematical
reasons why things may or may not works
so this is the PD duals F and remember
that my pin solution is U Theta right so
this is the U Theta this is what the pin
algorithm gives me and the objective
always in this problem there is a very
very specific objective which is that
you have to minimize the total error
right so the error is between U which is
the exact
solution we don't know it but it is
there and U Theta is the approximation
that we obtain with the algorithm that I
just described to you right so this is
this is sort of the objective so now the
question is that so this is what we want
to minimize we want to make this as
small as possible right depending on the
accuracy so in engineering for instance
it's usually around 1% so a couple of
digits three digits in some of the
applications it could be more in some
other applications it could be less now
what contrast spins from what is
standard supervised learning is that we
don't or we may not have in general we
don't have access to samples from the
exact solution so we have no control we
are never training the network directly
on this error because in let's say in
regression or classification uh
traditional use of machine learning in
images or text what you do is that you
you have some labels and then you have
the predictions of your network and then
you try to make the distance between
them as small as possible here we don't
have access to that right that's why
it's a fully unsupervised approach
however so what we do here is if you
remember we are working with the PD
residual um which we are of course
taking some Norm on it some LP
Norm um yeah so this is the lp Norm you
see so that you take the P power and you
take a 1 / P so just think of p = 2
would be like the root mean
square and P = 1 would be the mean
absolute many of you might have seen
this these objects okay so now this is
uh what we what we try to minimize what
we have some access to are these
residuals and I denote this by EG
sometimes people call this as
generalization error but think of it as
a PD residual because you don't have
access to this this is not even your
target you don't try to make it small
what you try to make small is this
mismatch here how much does of a
mismatch does it have at the level of
the PD and in fact in practice you don't
have access to this guy here what you
have access to is the training error
right so the training error is nothing
but a p root of the loss function
because if you remember this is my loss
function so the idea is that by
minimizing or making the loss F function
as small as possible can I sorry can I
somehow go back make this small make the
total residual small and eventually from
here can I go back and make the total
error small so let us try to sort of uh
put these questions together and this is
what I have done as somehow the key
theoretical questions the first thing is
and this is very important in some sense
is that we not searching for a vacuum
you're not searching for a vacuous
statement what do I mean by that so
remember that my objective or my OB in
some sense my objective is to make the
training error as small as possible and
underlying why I want to make the
training error as small as possible is
because it's after all a discretized
version
of the of the residual so I want to make
the residual as small as possible so the
question is can this even be done means
otherwise what are we doing right so in
other words do there exist parameters do
there exist uh in this class of neural
networks such that let's say the
training error can be made as small as
possible and the PD residual made as
small as possible because if these
errors are not going to be or these
objects are not going to be as small as
possible there's no point in doing
anything let's say say that this Epsilon
is like a 100 then what is the order of
the error will always be of the order of
100 right so it does not really help so
in other words what kind of neural
networks can we take such that these
quantities at least a priority can be
made as small as possible in principle
in practice whether this happens or not
is another question and we will see that
so that's the first question that we
have to ask is this even a feasible
problem in some sense can we even
address the feasibility
then of course as I said means in
practice we don't have access to this
error we only have access to this error
here the residual so it's natural to ask
if I make the residual as small as
possible does it automatically imply
that my total error the object that I
want to make as small as possible can
that be made as small as possible of
course trivially this is true if we have
a bound which looks like this it tells
us that the total error the object that
we want to
minimize is bounded in terms of some
constant times the PD residual so making
the PD residual small will automatically
imply making this will automatically
make this object small right so this
will somehow justify why we are going to
try and make this residual as small as
possible but we never have access to
this quantity because remember that this
quantity here is an sorry is an integral
right so we don't have access to this
quantity we always have access to it
through its discretization through this
training era so then we have to go one
step further and say that if you have a
small training loss because that's the
only thing that we can read out during
our algorithm if you have a small enough
training loss does it automatically
imply that the residual is small if it
is so or in other words if it is so then
or this will be true if you have a bound
which looks like this
so this tells us that as long as the
number of n is the number of quadrature
points so n is the number of quadrature
points so what does this tell us this
tells us that as long as you can make
the training loss small and the number
of quadri points as large as you want
then the total mean somehow this
generalization error can be as small as
possible this residual can be as small
as possible and from here you can go
back to the total error and make it as
small as possible so this is sort of the
let's say the hierarchy of questions
that we have so let me recapitulate so
what we want to do is first can we make
the training error as small as possible
and then once we have small enough
training error and large number of
quadrature points does it automatically
imply that there's a small residual and
does a small residual automatically
imply that the total error is so that
that's the mechanism through which pins
can work right otherwise how else can we
connect the training error to the total
error which is uh these are completely
different quantities they're sitting in
different spaces they have different
meanings so the only way we can do this
is through this route at least one way
in which we can do this is through this
route now let me try to explain this a
little bit more in detail so that you
don't don't get lost right so actually
this is not uh not that let's say
it looks a bit abstract but it's it's
not that unrealistic to or not illogical
to expect this uh if you know what I
mean so let me start by the first
question here the first question is are
we even solving a feasible problem in
some sense in other words can the total
error and the training error be made as
small as possible and the answer to that
actually is yes because this depends on
the PD residual this depends on the
smallness of the training error so how
can you do that so the answer is uh here
because remember that at the end of the
day so let me use this so we are solving
a PD which is given by here so now the
PD solution is although it's not always
the case in many many cases is actually
a smooth function so just imagine that
you have the heat equation so the heat
equation is um having one time
derivative and two space derivatives so
if the right hand side is even an
integrable function the solution of the
heat equation better have two space
derivatives and one time derivatives so
it's smoother than the F here than the
input here now this is not always the
case as you will see in the next lecture
but often this is the case that there
exists a Sol PD solution is going to be
smooth very good so what does that imply
that implies that if you look at the pin
residual so the pin residual is here
this is defined like this so you apply
the neural network you apply the
differential operator the neural network
take out the input now what is the F
here f is nothing but D of U right so
this is f is nothing but D of U so I
have simply substituted this here so now
we have the differential operator
applied to U Theta and the differential
operator applied to U and this gives us
a an estimate let me you know let me
just just for Simplicity let me try to
take this and expand it out for the heat
equation for instance
uh so that you're not completely lost so
for the heat equation if you remember so
let me take black here so this is object
that I'm going to sort of expand right
so I have D of U
Theta minus D of U right so D of U Theta
is nothing but DT the partial derivative
of U Theta minus Lan of U Theta minus DT
of uus
of U right let's put some Norm here so
this is nothing but DT of U Theta minus
U minus laian of U Theta minus U the
differential operators are linear so
this is less than or equal to by using
triangle inequality U Theta minus U plus
laian of uum
see or in other words this is nothing
but you can say U Theta minus U and I
don't want to sort of expand notation
too much but in what is called W1 p and
laian is a second derivative so this is
U Theta minus u in what is w2p one is in
time and the other is in space okay just
very formally I'm not not doing the math
so w1p simply means that the function is
close to something and its first
derivative is close close to something
to the first derivative of the same
thing here it means that these two
functions are close to each other the
first spatial derivatives are close to
each other and the second spatial
derivatives are close to each other so
when I measure things in this spaces wsp
it means that I'm demanding that not
only are two functions close to each
other but also the derivatives the
second derivatives the third derivatives
fourth derivatives and so on are also
close to each other and this s here as
you can see really depends on this
differential operator D if we have more
derivatives then we are going to have
more of this object there good so this
was essentially the content of what I
wanted to say for a nonlinear PD of
course as you can imagine this was a
linear PD so there everything sort of
worked out but for a nonlinear PD it's
slightly more complicated and you get
some things some constants which depend
on the function itself that's why it's
not linear right otherwise it would be a
linear PD but it's essentially what it
says is that the PD residual can be
estimated in terms of the difference
between the exact solution the function
and the neural network measured with the
right number of derivatives so that's
that's all all is there to this
mathematical derivation so all that we
need to guarantee so to guarantee that
the PD residual is going to be small all
that we need is to guarantee that there
are neural networks which are going to
approximate the PD solution ution which
is a smooth function with sufficient
number of derivatives right that that's
all that you do now this is where
already I think Ben has introduced what
is called a universal approximation
theorem so what is a universal
approximation theorem it's it's a very
important statement for uh for neural
networks it's one of the reasons why
people believe neural networks work so
well which is that if you take any
function mean this U is as long as it's
a continuous function or even an
integrable function then there always
exists a neural network even a shallow
neural network which is going to
approximate it in the right Norm as to
as much of a tolerance as accurately as
possible so this is the advantage of
neural networks that you think of any
function you see any function it it just
needs to be integrable in fact it needs
to be what is called measurable there
always exists a neural network which is
very close to it right so this is sort
of the basis of neuron networks now we
are invoking a similar kind of a
question except that we want not just
the function to be close to another
function but also its derivative should
be close to the derivative of the
function its second derivative should be
close to the second derivative of the
function and so on and there are similar
theorems for instance one of my own
theorems which uh say say this that this
indeed can be done that you can always
find neural networks which not only
approximate a function in an integrable
sense in an average sense but also
approximate the derivatives the second
derivatives the third derivatives and so
on so because the solutions of the PD
are in some sense smooth this
automatically imply and because neural
networks are Universal they can
approximate any function it
automatically means that there exists
neural networks such that the pin
residual is going to be small okay which
is what we wanted to right we wanted
this pin residual to be as small as
possible so that we are not solving a
vacuous problem and the same argument
also works for the training error
because what is training error after all
the training error just takes the if you
remember I have it somewhere yeah so the
training error is simply that it takes
this integral and it approximates it by
a quadri right so this is traditional
numerical analysis how do we take the
integral of a function and just
approximate it by some weighted
combination of the function evaluated at
points so as long as the function is
smooth the underlying function is smooth
there are many many different ways in
which you can do it even if it is not
smooth you can use Monte Carlo or
Central limit theorem so this tells us
that if the pin residual is small and if
there are sufficient number of
quadrature points remember that we have
smooth activations so this is typically
hyperbolic tangent then this this this
works quite well and this tells us that
from this result you can come to this
result so in other words that the loss
function or the training error provided
that there are sufficient number of
points can be made as small as possible
so you are not searching for some needle
in a haast stack probably at least uh
there is a needle somewhere mean you're
not searching for nothing in a ha stack
you know so this tells us that this kind
of arguments what they tell us is that
the problem that we're trying to solve
is in some sense uh well posed or is
feasible that you can actually find
neural networks such that this training
error can be made as small as possible
and if you have sufficient number of
quad points this automatically implies
that the that the total error is going
to be as small as possible okay or the
residual is going to be as small as
possible so in some sense these kind of
simple arguments of course for each PD
this has to be carried out by itself you
have to compute this kind of a this kind
of an estimate you have to you have to
argue why this result is true and so on
but the road map is right here and it's
it's it's fairly straightforward so that
part is easy that at least in terms of
The Well posedness of the problem it is
a wellos problem in the sense that there
are neural networks uh which sort of
minimize or there are new networks which
can make the training error in Principle
as small as possible whether you find
this neural networks when you start at a
certain point and you use stochastic rad
in descent this a different question
alog together and this is what we are
going to address in the next lecture
okay so so far so good this tells us
that it's a problem that we in principle
can solve but this is only good to know
right because in practice we are not
doing this in practice we are starting
with something we are trying to take
make the training error as small as
possible and from there we want to
conclude that the total error is going
to be small so this is we have to invert
this uh pyramid as it were so how do you
do that so let me just explain uh it's
not not very difficult at all so this
again goes to some papers that I wrote
some years back where this um argument
was first made but now of course many
people have fine-tuned it and have
improved it um these were the first
rigorous results on why pins pins would
work okay so the idea is very simple so
remember that we have essentially so
this is essentially the slide that
explains everything and I think after
that I will probably conclude because I
don't have that much of time probably
have 10 minutes okay good so the idea is
that now we know in principle that the
error can be made as small as possible
the training error can be made as small
as possible but given a small training
error can we go go the other way and can
we conclude that the total error is
going to be small so this is done in two
steps the first step we are going to
argue so again it goes back to this
picture here so this is done now right
so let's use a green and say that this
part is done that there exists neural
networks such that these errors can be
small so now the question that I'm
asking is this one so does it mean if I
have a small pin residual can I make the
total error small or in other words can
I get a bound which looks like this okay
let us try to see whether this can be
done and here is a strategy to do it it
is based on a property that we call a
square
civity this is there is no univers
notation but this is the term that we
used what does coity mean it's it's sort
of a stability property of the PD so
remember that this is a
PD so PD is nothing but um associated
with the PD as you'll see in a couple of
lectures there's something called a
solution operator which is think of it
as the inverse of the differential
operator because given an F it will take
give you the U okay so this this is how
the PD works so now the idea of this
coity so remember all the time f is the
input right so now let us consider
another input which is close to this PD
or in other words let us consider d uh U
Bar is equal to F Bar remember that my
original PD is Du equal to F and now I
have T Bar equal to F Bar so the idea is
i perturb f so I have a f bar which is
Clos close to F what happens to U and U
Bar right me this is a question of
stability I changed the inputs to the PD
a little bit does it also get reflected
in how the solution behaves and
coercivity says yes that is indeed the
case so this is precisely the question
so this is nothing but F Bar this is
nothing but F so it says that if you
inputs are close to each other the
output of the PD so this is a stability
of the inverse operator somehow of the
solution operator the outputs of the PD
are going to be close to each other and
in general this of course there are
constants because this PDS can be
nonlinear so this is like let's say
lipshits continuity roughly speaking
it's it's it's a continuity statement
it's a lip shits or a holder continuous
statement so this is a stability
statement we call it coercivity because
uh this is property that the PD can have
so remember that the bottom line here of
this entire estimate that I wrote down
is given small changes in the inputs to
the PD outputs to the PD
which which the PD
solution would also have very small or
relatively small changes because of
course this depends on the
constants now how can we convert this
into uh bounds in terms of residuals so
remember my objective and this is very
very straightforward and and but it
requires a little bit of concentration
let's let's try to have that
concentration so this is the definition
of error error is nothing but the neural
network minus the exact solution in some
Norm but remember that the PD itself is
Du equals to F again and again but what
is the neural network doing the neural
network is solving duu Theta is equal to
f plus the re
right this is because you always get
this residual so the neural network is
solving it's a it's a perturbation it's
a perturbation of F and the perturbation
is precisely in terms of the residual
now this can be small or big we don't
know that yet but this is a perturbation
so remember what does the stability say
that the difference between the outputs
is bounded in terms of the difference
between the inputs so these are the
inputs and du equal to f so this is the
this is what it is and du minus f is
actually the because it's a norm this is
this generalization error this
generalization error EG is nothing but
the norm of the resido rests in some nor
so that's it so this tells us that if
this quantity is going to be small right
so this guy is going to be small if
these this nonlinear terms these
constants are going to be bounded
automatically the exact solution is
going to be small and it solves our
problem because what we say by
minimizing the residual by making it as
small as possible we are saying that the
object that is making this residual as
small as possible is as close as we want
to the exact solution of the B okay so
this is one let's say a sufficient
condition this is not necessary
condition but it's a sufficient
condition which tells us that a
mechanism by which minimizing the
residual is a keen to sort of making the
or approximating the solution of the pde
is provided by this coer civity so this
is a mechanism by which you can convert
the properties of the PD into an error
estimate for the PIN for instance right
so this is uh if this is true we have to
verify for each uh different PD and this
is uh far from easy but uh that that's
that's how in the next lecture you'll
see some concrete examples and then but
this is not job done right because in
practice we don't have access to this
residual we only have an access at least
the norm of the residual we only have
access to the quadri right this is where
is it now the quadrature which is here
so we don't have access to the residual
we only have access to the quadrature so
but this is again there is a
relationship between them because this
is numerical analysis you have a
function and you have it uh you
integrate the function exactly or you
integrate it approximately so how Clos
the error is and this is essentially
what is called a quar chair so this is
done in traditional numerical analysis
for instance if you use um let's say
just random points this uh number is
going to be a half right because we know
that if you have random points uh
Central limit theorem tells us that you
can approximate uh the integral of a
function by just the what is called the
empirical sum or the point wise sum and
the error is going to scale like the
square root of the number of points so
the PD residual is given in terms of the
training error plus some constants of
course these constants they don't depend
on the PD itself they only depend on the
regularity of the smoothness of this
function here of the neural network and
the number of quadrature points so Alpha
is sort of the rate of convergence that
I Told You So if you think of Monte
Carlo s random sampling then this is
going to be a half so this is this is
and P is equal to 2 Alpha is going to be
equal to 1 so this is sort of the
mechanism so first if we can make the
training error small maybe I have even a
slide here uh yeah so let's say that uh
if I if I can make this error small the
training error is small and this is not
going to be an easy task you know so in
the next lecture you will see that this
is this is a hard task if I can make my
training error as small as I want and if
this constant is going to be bounded if
I take as many quadrature points as I
want then the residual is going to be
small so to make the residual small I
need to train my neural network in such
a manner that I have a small training
error and I have sufficient number of
quadrature points okay that makes my uh
residual so this you should think is
just the norm of the residual right
residual norm and then by using the
civity this is the one that I have
sketched out what you can do is that you
can uh you can say that the total error
is going to be small so again you have
to compute these constants here in some
sense means well this completely depends
on the properties of the pte as we will
see in the next lecture and the first
line here gives you guarantees that at
least the global minimum of this ET is
going to be as small as you want you
know this is a loss function um you you
never reach Global Minima this is
because it's a it's a non-convex
function but if you did then the the the
GL minimum can be made as small as
possible so that there is a there's a
hope but there's a possibility that this
quantity can be made as small as
possible this quantity can be made as
small as possible and if you have the
right kind of pde that can be converted
into making the error as small as
possible okay so this is sort of the
algorithm by which we can verify whether
pins can work or not at least one of the
this is as I said it's all sufficient
conditions it's not necessary conditions
so what we are going to do is is in the
next lecture at least part of the next
lecture is to look at some examples to
see whether it is feasible or not but I
keep on repeating and this is important
so that you get a sense for where we
stand the way it will work is you do
your training all right when you train
the neural networks you can actually
compute the training error explicitly
because this is this the loss function
is given to us and you take a square
root of it or a p root of it and you get
the training error that tells us
that tells us the Quantum of uh this
this loss function here and then if you
have sufficient number of quadrature
points this tells us that we need
sufficient number of quadrature points
that will make the residual small and
then depending on the properties of the
pde the total error is going to be small
so now you can also see that this this
Arrangement can fail in many ways right
for instance it can fail if you're are
unable to train the network well uh the
training GRS are going to be large it
can fail if you don't have sufficient
number of quar points if it can fail if
the PD itself does not have this
coercivity property it can fail if these
constants are going to be very bad and
there are or these constants are going
to be very bad so there are diff several
kinds of failure modes here and we'll
also see some examples of that so I
think I have come to the end of my time
today and uh as I said in the next
lecture we we sort of work it out uh
what is when will the project be online
people are more interested in that than
in the lectures soon soon is the
answer soon because some of you
requested that uh we don't
have a project deadline in the end of
May because people have exams so we had
to sort of change the schedule so now
there will be there will be no project
deadlines at the end of
May right uh someone is saying
something just because it is
graded yeah yeah it's okay means we I
think soon means either today or
tomorrow I cannot guarantee that because
the last time I looked it was more or
less ready but I think it's either today
or tomorrow that's uh who is saying now
what does she want now can you give us a
preliminary schedule for all the
projects uh okay this will be provided
okay I will tell the assistants to
release that but tentative I think we
just moved things a bit right so now
it's the pins project will be issued
today will be something towards the end
of April and there'll be something
towards the middle of June but the exact
dates I think they will they will
provide okay so in that case uh let's
meet in person and also on Zoom next
week bye-bye can I ask a question yes
sure um regarding the quador yeah uh
bounds uh why do you must use quador
bounds would there be other kind of
approximations that that we can use or
is the qu approximation the best
one any approximation is a quadrature
right what is a quadrature quadrature is
when you replace an integral which is a
continuous quantity by some sort of some
form of a sum okay which is a discrete
quantity so whether you use Monte Carlo
Monte Carlo you just if it's Monte Carlo
maybe I can just so instead of now of
course my pen has stopped working so if
you have F of Y Dy you're going to
approximate it by 1 / m f of Yi I from 1
to M so that would be Monte Carlo of
course in a in a probabilistic sense but
uh all of this are quadrature to me you
know quadrature is any way in which you
take a integral and you approximate it
discretly so everything whether it's
Monte Carlo quasi Monte Carlo means
house quadrature Newton codes all of
them are included in the same same
Ambit is that clear okay yeah it's
perfect thank you so
much any further
questions no so the recordings will be
provided and also the slides if they
have not already been put on they will
be put on pretty soon okay bye-bye